water mic everybody this is the way
start with another video on the channel
which is about mobile application
development so we're gonna be using
ionic framework so one code based can be
used to build mobile application for iOS
Android and also the Windows platform so
this is the website of the framework
ionic framework com
so this is what I'm gonna use so yeah
let's get started and I'm using Mac OS
even if you're on the Windows or Linux
that doesn't really matter this is a
cross-platform framework used no chess
and yeah so first thing we wanna do is
we are going to open a terminal so if
you know windows please open command
prompt and I'm just going to make this a
bit bigger and a bit bigger so first
thing we need to have two things
installed first of all we want to make
sure we have installed an old GS let me
take you to the browser and this is the
website for node.js so that's no Jess
dot org now it doesn't really matter
which version of node you guys use are
they using eight-point twelve point zero
or 10.11 that should not make any
difference but I will use long-term
support erosion so LTS stands for
long-term supported so I'm gonna be
using eight point twelve point zero so
basically you want to install node.js by
simply click on that it will start
downloading the installer file on Mac
its dot pkg file on Windows that's gonna
be Exe file so just download version of
node and let's go back to terminal
I'm gonna check node - we it'll tell me
what words you have node I'm using so as
you can see I'm using eight point twelve
point zero let me check the NPN version
NPM is six one four point one so we have
successfully installed two things no
Jess and also NPN and pin stands for
node package manager which is a package
manager used for node to install
a bunch of packages that you want to use
in your application so the next thing
what we wanna do is we wanna make sure
we install ionic CLI so ionic
command-line interface it's a really
helpful to build mobile apps with for
ionic by just typing some commands on
your terminal and it will do a lot of
things for you so I'm gonna go to
developer and gonna go to framework dogs
and here we want to go to ionic 4 so I
need for is in beta right now but I'm
still using ionic 4 because that's the
future installation tab and I'm gonna
click on CL our installation and here
it's telling me install and pin
installed battery organic so basically
NPN is a node package manager installed
as a command dash G is a flag with child
North packaging manager that please
install this globally in your PC or in
your Mac next you want to go and start
your application so if you want to use
ionic for application you have to type
this flag - - type is equal to angular
so there is a lot of things that has
been changed from ionic 3 to ionic 4
next we have a command to run
application once you type this command
in in CLI will create angular project
using angular 6 and ionic 4 and you can
run this same and you can run the
application by using this command ionic
serve next I want you to install one
more thing called Apache Cordova so the
canal to install this is simply as NPN
installed - G Cordova and if you're on a
Mac you're gonna have to type a sudo so
let's go back to terminal and here I'll
type sudo and pain install - JEE Cordura
and I'm gonna have to tie it
password to install that in my Mac the
reason for that is because I'm
installing this globally that's why it
required the password so as you can see
Cordova is installed as well so now we
wanna check the version of ionic CLI and
Cordova so I taught ionic - we will tell
me okay I've got a 4.1.2 CLI install and
I'm going to check for a Cordova and I
say Cordova - we and that gives me the
version of Cordova I have installed
which is eight point one point one so at
this point we have successfully
installed everything we need to start
drilling our hybrid mobile app now how
do we start a new project so being in a
terminal I'm gonna go to a folder which
I will be using to create a new project
so I'll do CD document and I'll say let
me just see that's gonna be hybrid
mobile apps and here
I've got one project I'm going to create
another one so I'll simply type I only
start and now if I want to check what
kind of project or what kind of template
I want to use then I will to check how
many projects are available so type
space - - list and that gives me all the
templates available which I can use so I
have an angular blank template angular
side menu angular tabs menu
anok angular ionic angular which use the
older version of ionic which was three
so we want to use ionic 4 so I'll type
ionic start and I'll say I want to use
tabs template and I'll plug it with tile
is equal to angular so I'll press ENTER
and it's going to start asking me what
kind of templates all to say tabs and
then I'm going to say ok it's asking me
that into
new app with Cordova to target native
iOS and Android so first we remember
that we installed Cola successfully now
I want to type Y and press ENTER and
it's going to integrate Cordova with my
project so I can build those app for iOS
and Android
so iOS basically don't understand
JavaScript but let's say angular I was
only understand objective-c or Swift so
credo wha is the is the guy let's say
which will take your angular code and
convert that to objective-c so that can
be run on iOS or iPhone or iPad devices
and on other side angular understand
Java or Cortland so Cordova support Java
it will take your angle a base code and
it will convert that code into Java so
you can run the same application on
Android as well and it's it it was
similar to Windows platform as well so
now it says okay dependencies install
and it's asking me install the free
ionic Pro SDK in connector up so I don't
have a paid ionic pro account so we'll
press n and press ENTER and there you go
our project has been created so I'm
going to type LS and I can see I have
another project called tabs so to start
the application I wanna have to go
inside that folder so I'll say CD tabs
and one thing I want to mention here
that everything is possible in Windows
and Linux as well it's just basically
I'm using terminal because I am on a Mac
and if you're using Windows you use
command prompt or PowerShell so we are
in the tabs folder so I'm going to LS
dash L which give me a list of the files
and folder that I have in this folder so
I can see I have a source folder I have
a conflict on XML will go through all
these files in the next video of course
let's start over application so I'm
gonna try
a command called Ilyich Serb press enter
and now it's going to open a browser
which will bring us a new app and we can
actually take this to to this virtual
desktop so we could see that so now it
looks like it's a vet page but actually
it's not a bad page so mobile ah
so I'm gonna click on days three dots
and I want to change this to developer
tools and then we will change from here
- let's say iPad pro or we can use this
for ionic iPhone 6 7 8 so now I'm gonna
close these oops I'll have to go back
guys sorry my bad and I want to put this
on the side so now you can see our app
is running so we have a contact tab
about Home tab and so far we have this
application now as I've shown you that
you have to go to developer mode and
then you will basically make your app
looks like a mobile app but there's
another way that is possible so we're
gonna go to terminal and I'm gonna press
ctrl C just stop the server which run
our application which was localhost 80
100 so first let me clear the console
and I'm gonna try up ionic sir - I'll
press Enter now it's gonna start the
server but - al is basically it's going
to start our application in a lab mode
so type yes
it's gonna install an ik lab and then it
will open up our server so right now it
basically didn't open up properly
because it hasn't installed okay so next
page it's opening now 8200 now there you
go so now when you type a lab which is
basically a flag that make your app look
like a mobile
so here I'm using iOS and if I go right
I can see the same app how it's gonna
look like in Android so you can change
or you can check apps side by side for
iOS and Android so this is how you can
see how my app is going to look like in
Android and how it's gonna look like on
is and believe or not they have a
support for Windows Mobile as well so
now this is a Windows Mobile and which
basically it's really poor it does not
really show anything nice here so we'll
just turn up because Windows Mobile are
dying there's no more Windows operating
system from mobile anymore
so we'll just target iOS and Android
platform so now if you want to kill the
server go back to terminal and then you
press can control C to start the search
to stop the server so there you go guys
this is how you set up your environment
for building hybrid mobile apps using
ionic in Cordova and also this is how
you create a project and start your
project it trust me it's really easy to
build a mobile application right now
using ionic all you got to do is type
some commands on the CLI and that will
do a lot of things for you
we are going to take a look at how the
file structure in our project is how to
create a project also what are the
templates available and a bit of about
ionic CLI so I mean terminal I'm using
Mac that's why I'm using terminal here
and if you're on Windows you can use
command prompt or you can use PowerShell
toward this course I'll be using
webstorm as an IDE I think this is the
best IDE for web development and also
for anything JavaScript later this is
the web best ID and also this is not a
sponsored video so let's go and create a
new project so in the last video you
remember that we install node.js we set
up our mixer Ally we set up our cordova
we create a project now let's go into
details about ionic CLI also the
projects so when you tied this command
ionic start you are basically performed
with some of the options so you said
okay what is your project name and then
it's gonna ask you what kind of template
did you want to use now there is a flag
with ionic
start and I'm gonna type space space - -
list and then I'm gonna press Enter now
this is going to show me all the
templates available for us to use so
right now I'm gonna expand the terminal
so you can see we have a blank side
letting a tab template and the time for
them is angular so whatever you see a
type is equal to angular that means you
are using that template with ionic for
framework and angular 6 now we have
older ionic framework as well which was
ionic 3 which has the type set as ionic
angular so if you select your project
and you want to select template form
ionic 3 and
use the same structure which was in
ionic three then you will use a type is
equal to IR the angular now this is the
latest ionic framework tutorial series
which is ironing for so we're going to
be using a type as angular so let's go
and create a new project all right so
now let's go and create a new ionic four
project using angular six so let's go to
the terminal and I'm going to type ionic
start - - at least it's gonna middle
it's gonna give me the list of all the
projects so I'm gonna say ionic start
and the next we are going to type the
project name which I'm going to call it
ionic for tooth and then we need to
define that the template that we want to
use so let's say if I don't define a
template and I just said - - type is
equal to angular press enter and it's
gonna give me three options to choose
from so there's only three options
available right now the reason for that
is because we already asked it to create
ionic for project and ionic for only has
three template blank side menu and tabs
so let me prove my point by pressing
ctrl C and getting out of this command
I'm gonna type only start and then we
say ionic for tooth and then ty we said
that is we go to higher League - angular
press Enter but this time it's gonna
give me option of about six template
because this ionic - angular basically
creates an ionic three project which has
about six - lets to choose from so let
me go back and press ctrl C let's clear
the terminal and I'm gonna type Alec
start and we'll name it only for tooth -
- type is equal to angular and then I'm
going to choose the black tablet and
next question it asking me is about
by targeting ios and android so if we
are creating an application to publish
on iphone or android we need a doorway
so it's saying basically integrate a new
outlet Cordova to target native iOS and
Android so let's press Y and press Enter
now it's gonna go and download and
integrate Cordova into our application
and it's gonna take few seconds I'm
going to pause the video once the
project is created or if there's any
question that come up I will let you
guys know during the product creation
the last question it will ask you is
about ionic pro SDK is the open source
project which basically great to build
your mobile application using angular
it's fast but also they provide some
sort of fraud services so I'm gonna take
you to documentation and here it says
products so basically I'll make four or
overall only has the pro version which
basically gives you some extra features
that you can use for example live deploy
we will have a separate video for each
of these functions as I have a pro
account with ionic but for now just
quickly a brief introduction to pro I
think it's basically it generates your
native packages in the cloud if you do
live deploy without going to App Store
replace or it can monitor you out for
example if your app crashes white
question it will monitor all those bugs
so this cool thing is about are having
problems we'll talk about later let's go
back and I'm gonna press M and then I'm
going to press enter now at this stage
our project is created and I'm going to
use a web strum to open this project so
let's click on open and I'm gonna go
ahead target that folder which was a
document test project only for tooth I'm
gonna click on open so throughout this
tutorial series I'll be using the Web
Store
which i think is a great ide by
JetBrains and it's not a sponsored video
guys it's just web strong or any overall
jetpack product is great so here is the
folder for artic tooth for project and
I'm gonna go through these all these
files okay so now let's go over to the
folder structure and a file structure of
our ionic 4 project so first of all
let's take a look at this resources
folder basically all your assets your
icon your splash screen images or
whatever image that you're gonna be
using in your application that will go
into your resources folder the reason
why I only has this set up separately is
because the angular required a sorry in
the Android required different kind of
resolution for your assets
I always require different kind of
resolution for your assets so iron link
and khaddama basically handle that
automatically for us so if you wanna
build a project for iOS you type a
command on your ionic CLI and it will
prepare your resources required
resources for iOS or require resources
for your ad right that's very simple now
let's go to some files outside our
source folder and get if you feel a
little bit kid you know what this get
ignore file does you will list out all
the folders which you don't want to be
included in your git repository angular
dot JSON
this is some configuration for your
angular so we can go through this letter
whenever we need something from this
file during the course let's move on
config dot XML is a really important
file in your ionic project so basically
it will list out your ionic ID a version
of your application a description a
title of your application also it will
list out all the platforms and then a
release out all the resources link
for that particular platform in this
file also all the plugins used from
Cordova and your application will be
here we have a package.json file which
is important as well it lists out all
over dependencies here you can see we
using angular we're using ionic and
lists out all the dependency dev
dependencies we can define scripts as
well for our custom builds there's not
much to look into these files these are
just default files getting generated
from ionic I will go through these files
whenever we need to understand any
property or any configuration from this
files let's go to the source folder the
first folder inside the source folder is
the app folder which will have all your
angular code so all your components your
services your pages directives will be
inside this app folder next we have
assets folder assets folder will list
out your one icon image that will be
used by Cordova or let's say ionic to
basically generate all your resources
from this one file these are some
environment variables we have a theme
your variable dot sass file which is a
global file and you can use these these
some of the color schemes are defined by
anak throughout your application and
this is this a global sass file for you
to use with global sass file here we can
list out all your all your basically CSS
and here we require this variable dat
sass file as well
next we have index on HTML file
basically this is the entry point for
your ionic app we have a some test
advanced karma is used to test your
application we have some polyphenols
main so main latias is entry file for
your angular project or let's say ionic
project this is like a star
file which basically start this is a
module that we want to use we have
defined that module adapter module
that's or our component so here we were
tears config leads out some more
configuration let's talk about this
later
in this video we are going to learn
ionic CLI so first of all we will add
iOS platform to our project so let me
just bring my CLI to the right so we can
look at the commands that are right so I
have a look at this folder structure
right now we have a source folder
resources folder e to see folder node
modules folder so now I'm gonna type a
command here ionic core Dora platform
add iOS and when I press ENTER now it's
adding iOS to our project using cool or
fetch or Cordova iOS version 4.5 points
zero right so as you guys can see the
platform is being added so if I go to
our project our view we can see there is
a platform that named iOS so when I
click on that I can see the file
structure that can be opened in Xcode so
if you are familiar with Apple's Xcode
which is ready for iOS Mac iPad app
development that project can be open
directly there so now most of you will
be familiar with Java Android projects
so here we can add Android project as
well so I'm gonna type ionic core let me
just make this bigger if I'm able to not
not so I like her door
I will keep my mouse cursor here
platform add and right now it's gonna go
and download the Android color version
of 7.1.1 and she'll take few minutes or
few seconds depending on your computer
and your internet connection
once it adds the idroid platform then
we'll go and talk about this
okay so the Android project is there as
well so you can see we have an Android
project and iOS project now just get you
from livid CLI commands you can remove
project as well so if I go I on ik
cordova platform remove android it will
go and remove the platform form of a
project so he can see removing platform
Android from config dot XML file and a
Cordova that platform array in package
dot JSON file so let's take a look at
here in the platform folder we don't see
a Android folder anymore so if I go and
open package the JSON file here we can
see that we have a platform listed iOS
but we don't see Android so let's go
back to terminal and we can add iOS
platform sorry the platform is already
there it says platform is already exist
so we can add a droid platform so I'm
gonna click on a little platform add
Android it's gonna go and download
Cordova and write a game and then it's
going to it's going to basically create
a platform for us now these are the
basic commands in ionic CLI to remove
and add a project once the Android
project gets added to our project will
add another type of project called a
browser so we could run our application
in the browser while developing and to
test our application we can use actual
device so I'm just waiting for this
platform to add
all right so right now you can see it's
generating resources 18 resources
generated now platform is added there we
can see platform iOS and Android is
listed in package the JSON file also we
can take a look at config and in config
we have a platform iOS with a platform
and right now I'm gonna add let's go and
clear the terminal I'm gonna add ionic
go to platform add browser so we're
gonna add a browser platform through our
project as well so we can do all the
development test or application in terms
of functionality in our browser and then
we can run this application to the
actual device whether it's iOS or
Android device or even a Windows device
guys so once this gets added the first
thing we wanna do is we want to ambulate
at this project so let me go and open
the Chrome browser first okay so the
browser project has been added we can
make a look at a platform folder and we
can look at our package to JSON file
which should have browser as a platform
as well I'm gonna take my terminal back
to the bottom so we could look at the
project and the files and I'm gonna
clear the terminal and the next I wanna
do is we wanna run our application onto
a browser so I'll say ionic Cordova
emulate browser okay now it's gonna go
and build our project right now we can
see ee ee ee folder is empty but when
the first time we build up a project it
will not be ante anymore it will have
all the JSON and a production version of
our code the
sit into www folder so the first time
we're building this project that's why
it's taking a bit longer alright so as
you can see it took few seconds a few
minutes depending on your computer and
now our application is up and running
now this is how you emulate your
application to your browser now the
reason why I'm showing it the first is
because when you emulate your project to
your browser using Cordova it will put
all your native functionality to the
browser as well but for just development
purposes we don't have to ambulate our
project your browser but what we can do
is I'm gonna press control C and let's
clear the terminal and instead of using
a liquid over ambulette browser i'm
going to use a simple command which is
ionic serve this is going to do the same
thing it's going to build our project as
you can see this tablet of leaf folder
is not empty anymore
and now it clearly says our project is
running on localhost called 8,100 also
the external IP that we can target
online to the ones exceed or 1.7 called
80-100 so it's going to build a project
and it's gonna show that into the
browser there are pros and cons using
only Cordova amulet browser but we will
talk about these later in the course now
as you can see our project running the
last command I want to show you is ionic
serve - AL - al is basically ionic a
library you have to install in your
project will which will basically make
our application look like it's running
on a mobile so right now it's asking me
it's our league lab is not installed you
want to install it I'll type e Y and
then I press ENTER and it's gonna go and
download our graph for me
start my server using Alek lab now the
once or server starts as you can see
here we have iOS version and we have an
Android version of our application which
is great so you can take a look at the
UI of iOS and also the Android version
so I don't really run this in
development but as just let you guys
know this is available for you so if you
do only serve - al it's gonna run your
server on ionic lab which will show your
app as it's running on your native
device
I'm going to show you how you can
emulate your project to iOS a simulator
I'm using Mac one thing to mention here
you will have to have a bag to develop
application for iOS platform so let's
get started so this is an app in the
last video we've seen how we can do
Arctic serve and then that will open a
browser and it will launch your
application now also we want to emulate
this project to an actual iOS simulator
for that you need to make sure that you
have few free software installed
for example I'm gonna go and open Xcode
now Xcode is an IDE developed by Apple
and it's basically used to develop
native iOS applications now to install
Xcode you want to go to app store on
your bag and simply search for Xcode
here but here you will see your Xcode
and you will click on download it will
you'll see get click on get and then you
download that now we are using Xcode
version 10 which is the latest version
of Xcode so here I'll type artic cordova
emulate iOS and here first of all I want
to check how many devices do we have in
our system we could use to emulate so
I'll say - - list and I press ENTER it
will go read Xcode and it will give me
the list back so I'm going to move my
terminal to the right so we can see so
these are the devices that I can emulate
- and it basically shows us the iOS
version as well I could use iOS 12 or
iOS
11 point 2 so now let's clear the
console or terminal so I'm gonna type
here ionic core Dora ambulate iris - -
target the target is the flag which lets
you specify a device that you want to
emulate - Seoul say - the target is
- let's ever let this project to iOS
troll with iPhone aids of the I phone -
8 and then I'll press Enter or return
on a Mac so it's doing all its stuff so
I can see my I'm a little now on the
screen and also I can see this ironing a
blank template okay so this is how you
start your emulator and upload your
project - I assume a letter now another
platform that we want to build an
application for is Android now it is
pretty straightforward to emulate your
project to Android as well so basically
in turn writing this command and it
could or emulate iOS you will just
simply say only code or
emulate Android and I use the same flag
- - target is equal to I from 8
welcome to my Windows PC so to emulate
your ironing project to Android
simulators you're gonna need to install
Android Studios if you go to
developer.android.com slash studio here
you can download android studio which is
about nine twenty three megabytes i've
already downloaded and installed android
studio as you can see at the bottom and
it's already up and running now what I
did basically I just created a new
project so if I go and close this
project you will see this screen
all you have to do is create a new
project so let's go a creative project
he'll type the name for the likes next
next and then eventually you will see
this kind of a folder and you will see
stuff like this now once you open a
project you want to go to Tools menu and
wanna go to AVD manager now let me
explain what is AVD manager so basically
it lists out all your virtual devices
now let's go to web strong and let's try
loading these devices someone close this
close Android studio as well let's open
up a web strong and this is the project
that I'm working on right now call
expenses is the expense log wrap with a
lot more functionality that you find in
usual application we've touched this job
so let's get back to work so I'm gonna
type ionic go to emulate and try - -
list now it's gonna give me the list of
emulators so here I have an X file X
Nexus 6 and pixel to run this project to
pixel or any of their devices
I can specifically type - the target is
equal to the device name let's run our
application on Nexus 6 on top
ionic to emulate and write target is
equal to Nexus 6 now one thing to
mention here the name of the device is
case sensitive so if it's if either
as a capital letter you must have a
capital letter so I press ENTER now you
know it's gonna go ahead and build a
project and now it's going to run on an
emulator you see Nexus 6 device and the
Android version that you would see in
Android studio but I'm gonna open that
so I'm not sure what version it's
running right now but it's some
something's running so let's take a look
at how and how long it takes to run them
a letter it's building the project okay
it says build successful in six seconds
and you can see how a murderer is
getting online now this is a replication
that it actually rained so yeah that
that's pretty much it is guys for this
video and this is how you use and
emulate your project into ionic
using ionic CLI - iOS Android
we're gonna take a look at the code
itself we've learned so far how to
emulate projects to Android devices and
iOS devices we also learn how we can add
platforms like Android iOS and browser
and we have covered the basics of ionic
basically the workflow and the tools you
need to setup to basically start
developing an ionic or we can say hybrid
mobile app so right now I'm going to go
and show you guys what is the project
structure what each file does so first
of all I have created a blank project so
if we create a new project and you will
use the template gland this is what
you're gonna get so there is pretty much
nothing strained so your ionic start
blank and name of the problems I've
shown you how to create a project right
so I'm starting with the blank template
now this is the template that we're
going to be using the source code is
going to be available on my github
account so I'll link to that as well so
do I need - L so - I'll flag basically
will help us to read order replication
will show our application into native
looking devices but at the end of the
day you still want to test on the actual
simulator whether its iOS or Android now
this is our application is running I'm
just gonna make this a little bit like
this and then we don't need to keep the
terminal up and running now that's it
so the first of all let's go through the
project structure so we have seen some
of the project structure in the previous
video but let's go something let's go
into details now the first thing you
will see a source folder which will have
everything related to your app I want to
go to main dot es so the main tells TS
file is an entry point it's an entry
point for the whole application here you
can see that we basically import a
nibble product mode which is right now
it's not true because we're developing
so we've a platform browser dynamic
bootstrap module add module
then that's what we imported so here we
have an app a module so a good app and
this is the applicants basically the
main that es file is telling the
compiler that okay this is our main
entry module start our application from
here now once you start your application
it will go and then do all its
processing related to angular stuff so
this is nothing more than angular module
with some ionic Anik modification so
right now if you are familiar with
angular you feel at home so we have ng
module we have a declarations we define
all the components here with the entry
components which is basically empty
right now we imported browser module
ionic module for route and a protein
module so in ionic for basically we have
a different lazy loading concepts or
relays load different modules so here
basically create the module this is an
entry point entry module for our app
actually have a prod module which is
imported by add module so your app
running module let's take a look at app
our routing module so basically what's
happening here we have a two routes
defined in a routes variable which has a
type of routes now we download it we
actually imported router module and we
pass in this routes variable now what I
want to do is I want to explain what is
lazy loading basically let's say that
you have your application of about 500
pages or 1000 pages now when you start
your application if you are willing to
load those 10,000 or thousand pages your
application is going to be loaded it's
gonna take a lot of time to load that
application
so this is where lazy loading comes into
play basically you learn an application
alone just one Pacific main module and
then you load the rest of the modules
depending on the browser URL or
depending on which one you requested so
what I want to do here I want to go and
create a couple of modules separate
pages with separate module and then
we'll link to those so here we can see
we have a lazy loaded this page home so
basically it says go to this route if
there is no route defined and it
redirects to home which again matches
with this path and it says path match
it's set to full it's gonna go to this
module by default so let's go to
terminal and I'm gonna create a new
terminal here and here I'm gonna type a
command ionic G now it tells me which
which what kind of stuff I want to
generate so I'll say I wanted to write a
page and I would say okay let's say
about Us page I'm gonna press Enter
now it's going to generate a module for
us it's going to read the page for us
and it's going to automatically load
that to our app a routing module as you
can see now we have about us which
basically leads to about us about a
start module which is here and then we
have this about Us page module which is
basically the name of the module nothing
more than that so I'm just going to
close this now we want to create another
page let's just say contact press ENTER
now it's gonna create a page of contact
also it's gonna create a module so
basically you go inside a module you see
it has a route part set to empty and it
defines the component it imports the
component as well so let's close this as
well now let's say that we don't see
these automatically
but we want to ride along so basically
you simply go and define a part it
happened in the part you want to match
according to the URL in your browser and
then you type a key load children and
then you specify part to the folder
which is basically here about us and
then next you say go inside this folder
look for this file about us stop module
30s file which is defined here and then
you define a hash and I'm saying
basically go inside this folder go to
this about a start module file and then
go inside this file and then look for
about Us page module and if I look at
about a space module here you can see it
basically has a routing implemented so
it has this about Us page component
implemented in this module so how do I
link to this now this various ways that
you can do navigation using angular in
ionic for let's take a look at so we
want to go to the home which is
basically a simple route which basically
if there is no route it will go to the
home which we actually define here I
brought models around the top to go to
redirect your home if there is no URL
there
okay so now I'm just going to get rid of
this again the st. is now there's
nothing here so I'll just go and create
let's just say use eye on button we do
let's just say and we want to go to
let's just do an anchor tag or do H ref
and here are defined simply I want to go
to let's go back to our model so I want
to go to about us let's copy this and
paste that here and I'll say about us
let's save it and you will see a button
I don't see the name here so maybe
about us here who top it in that's fine
I would just wanna get rid of this is
all all we can define we can do at
refute slash about us
let me just remove that okay so then if
I click on about us they'll take me to
the about us module and it loads that
component so if I go to about us more to
and he'll take us to here and they will
load this about us page now let's go to
contact and here we have this component
they're gonna go back to home no home
sorry sorry home yes it's a home page
and then here I want to add another
button and then yeah I will do and find
a promoter that's just contact we copy
that and we go to let's just close right
stuff here and that's just to contact
here let's save this we have two buttons
about us and then we can say contact now
let's go to contact page in here I want
to define a button
oops not that one let's make it bigger
so button sorry hon - button oops not
bad what I'm doing button and we do at
raf and say - home sir it similar we'll
copy this we want to go to about us page
I want to paste it here as well let's
save this now we can navigate between
these file so let me just say home here
and then we have a contrabass or to say
a homepage here okay so now if I click
on app home it'll take it back to the
whole module and reload this homepage
and if I go to contact attack with the
contact page and then I have another
button here to the contact page and I
can go back to home so as you can see we
basically can do a lazy loading here so
routing with the lazy loading alright
so that's about this video guys in the
next video we're gonna take a look at
how we can use some of the components
provided by ionic library
we're gonna take a look at how we can
use action sheet in your application the
action sheets are great when you have to
have some sort of a pop-up which will
get the user to type into options this
is actually the for example if former
delete some component a dividend value I
can say hey you want to delete click on
delete you want to share you click on
share play model favorite and cancel so
we're gonna create a dese model in this
video but you might be thinking what am
I doing here there's a lot of things
happening here already so for that I'm
actually going to create a new project
and then in that project so let me just
open the terminal first and then here in
the terminal and just make it bigger for
you guys all rights do this in the
terminal I'm gonna create a new ionic
form project and then we will add action
sheet store it tired and I'm gonna make
that too angular
press enter now it's gonna ask me what
will be your project name don't say
ionic tutorial and then what template do
I want to use so if you are creating
your application with the tabs UI you
can select tabs which will automatically
generate a code for you where you will
have some tabs already placed for you to
use we want to work on side menu then
you will use side mini template which
will already have some sort of code
which will do read aside we need for you
but all what I do here is we want to
create a blank template and then using
that blank template we want to learn how
to implement some components and after
that we will learn how we can create a
UI including tabs in the side menu so
one bolt into place so that's let's get
started with blank template so I'll
select that and it's going to go and
download now it's asking me in trigger
Janu Abbott Cordova to target native iOS
and Android I'll say yeah why not I'll
just integrate trade over to our
application right so the project is they
were done
now basically it's asking me whether I
want to integrate my ionic project -
ionic pro SDK well I don't have a count
as if yet now for ionic Pro so that's
why I'm going to say and and press Enter
alright solver project is created now
I'm going to open that project in web
strong
so let's the open web strong and here
let's let's take it to that window there
okay so now I'm gonna go and click on
open
we're gonna navigate to that folder any
tutorial and I'm going to open that now
this is a similar project that would
just create it in the last video it's a
blank project it's got nothing more than
just a boilerplate code to run our
application so we're gonna go inside
this and I'm going to go to terminal
and I'm gonna simply type a command
ionic sir - L I'm going to click on this
browser so it will go and open that so
now before we can open this project into
a lab we need to install ionic lab tell
you why press ENTER this will install
ionic lab now and then it'll open our
application
as you can see after installing ionic
lab it automatically opened up so right
now we're looking at is version of our
application though you'll take a look at
Android and also Windows I'm just going
to scroll down this is Android guys and
that's a Windows down there so we
continue with Android and Windows so
let's take a look at code
now in the source folder as I explained
in the last three videos about this
blank project so we're going to go to
app and here we have this app a module
add module is the main module of your
application we have a app a routing
module which I've already explained to
you guys how the routing and a lazy
routing works in angular 4 so here we
have this app running module add module
we have an app component we have app
component HTML file but we have this
ionic app with ion router outlet
basically let's take a look at the outer
outlet what it does if you're familiar
with angular it will tell the
application this is where I want to
start my routing so this is the main
entry point for your routing so now what
we want to do here we want to learn how
we can create an action sheet so I'm
gonna go to app component or we can
simply go to our home page and do our
action sheet because app components
nothing more than just a placeholder for
routing it does not really have anything
so basically when Apple you can start it
looks at this and router and it goes to
the routing module and looks at what
it's supposed to load you go to app
running module a here you can say
there's no path it will redirect to home
so we're gonna do all over logic home so
let's go to homepage and here if I'm
just gonna go and remove all these and
I'll say hey I want to have I on button
okay and then inside this I'll say hello
action sheet will press command S it
will save the project and will open that
into her app so here we can see how this
hello action sheet burn which does not
do anything as now so we want to do want
to create an action sheet but I'm going
to take you to and a a documentation for
this so you can go and continue learning
after you learn how to implement these
kind of UI components so here we have an
action sheet slide up from the bottom
edge of the device and display the set
of options with ability to confirm or
action or our kin selection
so actually sheet can sometimes we use
as an alternative to menus however they
should not be used for navigation so
your API and in API will give us some
sort of code snippet which we can use so
now I'm going to go back to the code and
here will just open home dot T as well
we're gonna do a logic and then here I'm
going to create a constructor function
constructor and say public and that's
the action
[Music]
okay so i fast-forwarded the function so
basically let me go and explain the
function what we've done so far so in
the constructor we added this action
sheet controller service and I stored
ourselves into the variable and called
action sheet and then we create a
function which is the async function and
I named it present action sheet and then
inside that function we create accounts
variable which basically have this a
sink and a weight now we are using this
action sheet which I injected into this
constructor function and then we call
the method create and then we got some
few properties to define so we could
show the action sheet so we ever had
what would be the header of that - sheet
what is the mode of our action sheet any
buttons available in action sheets so we
can define as many buttons as we want
and then after that we have this await
action sheet the present method which
will basically create an action sheet
and then make it appear right so now we
have this function I'm going to put this
function and call it when I click on
this button so we go to the home dot
home page dot HTML and here I'll use a
click and then I'll just call it present
action sheet I'll save the project and
now our compiler should be done in like
five seconds yet it's done I'm gonna
click on hello action sheet and there we
go so we have an action sheet so I can
click on it and then it will just
disappear so now if I go to let's just
say home pages or tears and here I have
had a handler on the button basically
it's a function that will be called once
you click that button so let me go to
the console here in the browser and I
want to show you that when I click on
we'll see you click me on the console so
click on that and then I will just go it
down and I click on that cancel button
and there we go we see you click me so
you can see that we can call any
functions from anywhere in our
application on this button so this is
very useful if you want to perform any
action and also just to mention that you
can add a multiple buttons here the for
example this is one button in an array
we have I'm just gonna move this red
down so it's better and cleaner to look
at so here I'm just gonna copy this and
I'm gonna add a comma here I'm gonna add
another button and I'll just say role
would be let's just say this
tri-tip alright and then the text would
be hello icon we can say add I'm gonna
save the file
and I'm gonna here say you added me okay
and I save the file again and then take
a look at do we get two buttons now so
if I click on this button to close the
console I click on this I would get this
button hello
and I cancel so he would define a role
that has this cancel so I will just go
down but if we have another button we
define a role to destructive that means
it'll go into the list so we can have
like a multiple buttons here with a
destructive role so this code make
another one come on make another one and
I saved the project and this time when I
click on that hallow action sheet you'll
see multiple items appearing so click on
this and here we have multiple buttons
I'm going to go to console and just
clear this thing out now we're gonna go
to actually she's gonna clean download
the butter and says you had it me if I
click on that I click on cancel button
you see that you click me so you can
perform any kind of action onto one of
these buttons alright so this was a
quick introduction to how you can use
the components using there
the classes
we'll be learning how we can use a
component a library provided by ionic so
ionic apps are made of high-level
building blocks called components and
components allow you to quickly
construct an interface for your app and
ionic comes with a number of components
including models pop-up and cards
we're not take a look at what's
available in ionic and I'm going to show
you how you can use it now before we
start I would like to give you a demo
why do you even bother using components
or UI provided by ionic but here we have
a same application running for iOS
Android and a Windows platform and I
know Windows platform is dying and ionic
is not really supporting anymore but we
have a third option here when you start
your application with the flag - owl you
get this lab so here you can see how
your application is going to look like
on iOS and Android and Windows so now if
I click on this button which basically
it's a fab so let's see I'll click on
that I get this action sheet so you
probably use a lot of mobile application
on iPhone so you see this action sheet a
lot in your iPhone application a similar
to Android we're going to take a look at
if I tap here it shows you the action
sheet but look at the UI UI is pretty
much Android looking UI so you see this
kind of you are in a stock Android
phones for example Nexus series from
Google so this is a stock Android UI or
we have this Windows which is going to
make you laugh so if I click here you
get this sort of things here because
Windows platform is not supported
anymore
and I don't know why they kept that in
ionic but so you got the idea
so benefits of using ionic components is
that you write one HTML you write one
HTML with a couple of seasons classes
and ionic take the responsibility of
making your app
look native to the Pacific platform for
example if they're running on iOS then
app is going to look like it's a native
app on iOS even though the whole app is
running on is it running on platforms of
that component we'll talk about that web
UI kit that provided by different
platforms so now let's take a look at
the documentation of ionic so here we
have ionic action shades we have alerts
so here if I click on action shades that
says it's show actually it's a bit slow
but it's going to show you this is the
action tree that you can use now what
you can do here you can basically use
this one code and just put that in your
application and when you build a code
for a Pacific platform that would
automatic will be converted to make it
look like native so we have alert we
have our badges we have buttons so let's
take a look at the button so these are
the buttons available that you can use
and it's gonna look like these in your
iOS so you see cards everywhere on
iphone applications we have a checkbox
and that's gonna be a check bar for your
both platforms we have data and time so
now you see a lot of application have
this date picker that you can choose
date phone that seems very complicated
to create but ionic provide this nice
little code snippet of code which you
can use in the application and will show
a date picker
so before I just take these and I copy
this and I just paste that into my
application so let me put that into
somewhere let's just go to Home tab I
know you guys can't see it but I'll show
you that is later so I'm just gonna put
that a simple UI into one of the
applications we are running so I'm gonna
paste this here but save it let's go
back to our application right and here
we have this date because if I click on
that there you go I can you know pick
the date for iPhone
and if I click here I can pick the date
here so it didn't actually work on
iPhone but working customizing we can do
it I can customize Pacific the platform
we have a fab fab is really cool that
basically gets you a button which has
some Z index so it stays on the top of
all the other components in your
application Apple I have created this
button the plus button
with the help of fab so that there was
no fab that would be very hard to create
this kind of a button that basically
stays on the top of all the components
you have if a grid grid is basically
used to create a layout in your
application for example you want to
customize the layout of your page and
you want to have some small cards bigger
card so you use a grid the grid is a
great infinite scroll so a lot of
application have this kind of infinite
scroll guys so you can just keep
scrolling and the data will be loading
according to your scroll so what happens
is if you wanna like if you're working
on an application where you have a lot
of data sets and it's not you're not
able to fit those that I said in just a
small screen so what you can do is you
can use this infinite scroll and
basically the amount of data you can
load and at that screen that will only
be loaded but when you go scroll down it
will load the next data into an array or
in your object I will show you how you
can use it later but let's go to quickly
what are available so we have our input
fields available we can still customize
that list is there loading the loading
is one of the cool thing that I only
trial it's really easy to create as well
so if I click on show loading
I'll show you this kind of loading
please wait so a lot of application use
these kind of loadings when they want to
load data basically they make an API
call to some server running in the wall
and then they wait for data to be
received and during that time you don't
want your user to just stare at your
application without knowing anything so
what do you do create a loading so that
user knows that something is coming so
they get a
we have a menu menu is really great it's
easy to use so if I tap here and then I
can see the menu bar
Weber model model is one of the other
great UI component provided by ionic if
I click on one of these you'll pop the
model up and I can have that I can have
the page it's basically a model not an
exact page and I can use that for all
the components that I want to put in
this basically is used mostly for sign
up and login page which don't really
require to be there all the time so you
create those on the go by baby quitting
a button pressing on that and you create
a model now let's go to now so laughs
basically you see in iPhone applications
the way there's a lot of child component
that you want to show then use now so
one app can create a model or another
map inside this and then that map can
have another lab inside this so you can
just continue are doing basically child
to child and child to child components
pop or let's take up a popover so
popover is like you have some sort of
text going at the back and you see when
the I scroll down you see the popover
you see the text just a little bit blur
that means popover now secondly range
there's a lot of time you want to maybe
increase decrease some sort of a UI or
CSS or something in your application
then you can use this kind of company
that's really really great sometimes you
want to change the data it will have
some sort of UI which helps you to do
that and this is great refresher a lot
of times people go to one of the page in
your application and then they want to
refresh the data for example the data is
coming from the back end and you go to
the page and during while you were on
the page the data updated in the back
end and your API basically doesn't drink
any event or doesn't really emit the
data to the front end so what do you do
you clearly fresher and you get the user
to tap and swipe down and that makes
that that makes the refresher now on
that event you can call API and load
some more data and obviously you're
gonna be using angular with ionic to
create all this logic this is just a UI
component which is great and very easy
to implement in our application but
obviously the backend logic the
battlecode in Imbler will be done by us
we have a search bar is select so a lot
of ways you can select we have this
female gender selection game selection
there yo we have notification selection
and there's different types of selection
that you can customize slides now a lot
of time when your application loads for
the first time you see some sort of
introduction of your application so that
means they basically create slides the
slides are very easy to create with
ionic all you do is just copy paste this
and fill the data in and that's what
goes into your slides really good stuff
if you want to create the same kind of
slide in your native Android or iPhone
or Windows code you I think you're gonna
take much longer so there's much not
going to implement and make it look like
that nice Spheeris a lot of times you
wanna have speakers there yeah we have
experience tabs
tabs are really a core component that is
required for any application you go to
iPhone or Android
now all the bigger enterprise level
application have some sort of tabs UI
then you have the tabs at the bottom so
I can show you this this is the tab as
well
now we will learn how we can create
interface including tabs also with a
menu bar so right now I don't see them
anywhere here but we'll implement that
later so toast toast a great way to show
show some sort of message on an event to
the user
for example if they are going to sign in
and once the sign in it should be a
message that you successfully logged in
so if I tap here you see the toast here
and it stays for a few milliseconds or
one second two second you can define the
time there as well but click here and
there you go so we got different sort of
sorts toasts available ritual scroll so
we have a wheel scroll so it says your
father was successfully but it's gonna
go all the way to five hundred entries
that's called a little scroll but these
are the components that are provided by
ionic framework now as I as we are
literally angular so it not and alert
for but ionic four which means this
documentation is not a stable
documentation this is a beta
documentation and they will be adding a
lot more components a lot more
information to these document now if I
take you to the documentation of the
older version which will give you some
more UI components so let's go here
we're gonna go to ionic framework and
then here I'm gonna go to developer and
I'm gonna go to framework dogs now this
is ionic three dogs you can see I look
for is coming but we already started
learning ionic four because it's it's
pretty much done we basically got what
we need to build application the dynamic
for but there's gonna be a lot of
improvements will be coming in but the
structure and the core core technology
is there already if I go to components
you'll see a lot more options here
compared to I think there's not much
more but maybe a toolbar is another one
that you have here so you see this for
the toolbar stuff like that so yeah
that's that's about you guys and now
thank you so much for watching this
video that was just a quick overview of
what's available in ionic for what are
the UI components and in the next video
we'll learn how we can
implement some of the nice components UI
commands into our application
add some more UI components available in
ionic 4 so the first component that I
wanna show you is alert alert a great
ways to offer the user the ability to
choose a specific action or list of
actions alert can include text input
buttons they can provide the user with
important information or require them to
make a decision so what is an alert
alert is a dialog that present uses with
information or collects information from
the user using inputs an alert appears
on the top of your app content and must
be manually dismissed by the user before
they can resume interaction with the app
it can also optionally have headers sub
headers and messages also you can add
buttons you can have inputs you can do a
lot more stuff in alerts but they're not
recommended if you have some sort of
functionality that you want to perform
so basically if you need a signup form
and it's got a lot of information I will
recommend you guys use a model instead
of alert we'll take a look at what is a
model later in the course so let's get
started with creating an alert let's go
to homepage that here's file and here
you can see I have imported alert
controller and also I've injected that
into a constructive function so we could
use that in our class so now let's get
started with creating a simple alert I'm
going to start with defining a scene
function which I'll call it present
alert and then we create a constant so
I'll just do a Const and I'll say this
is alert that I'm creating and then I do
await these dot alert actually have
forgot to change the name of this action
sheet to alert controller so alert
controller
I was I was usually the same file in the
last video so this is why I had that so
so this dot alert controller got the
create we pass in an object and that's
going to take a header which were
passing
alert and then another value can take a
sub header as well so do sub alert when
I put that into single totes so sub
alert now we can say what is the message
up that alone will do message and then
inside that say hey this is the alert
message and then also gonna put that
semicolon so comma there and then we can
have a button so the buttons and then
that will should take a button okay and
then we can simply go and present it so
just wait dot sorry alert dot present
okay I'm gonna save the file let's go
and wait for it to compile so it's
compiled down I'm gonna click here that
should present an alert so it's not so
we gotta go back to home that page and
then we type in click event which will
tell you present alert save it wait for
it to compile the project and then when
you click on it you should be able to
see a lot so here we have alert
subheading and a message in a button
which will dismiss the alert all right
let's go to ionic documentation and here
I'm going to take you to alert and let's
click on API which will tell us what's
available for us to use from alert so
here you can see we have a buttons we
have inputs we have the usage and code
snippet as well that you can use so here
you can see we have a simple alert which
we just created your long message alert
that's what we can create multiple
button cancel open model delete so you
can perform an action depending on what
you want to do so let's take a look at
that so here I would like to go and
create an action sheet when I
click on present alert so let's go back
and here we want to go and I'm just
gonna make it a bit smaller so we can
see it what's the file just import
action sheet controller that would be
from on angular and then I'm just gonna
inject that as well so just to prorate
action sheet action sheet controller
that's fine so now here I'm going to do
a handler for a button will remove okay
instead of passing a string we pass in
an object now here we define a text I'll
say cancel role would be cancel as well
that goes into string and then here we
do handler and I'm gonna pass in an
event here so not only write basically a
function when you get click it's what do
you want to do so do console dot log and
say you clicked me so you click me okay
so now I can pass in another button so
we can have a multiple button here so we
just do a comma and then I'm gonna pass
in text okay and then we don't define
the role now we just simply say let's
just do CSS class we can do a secondary
and then we can pass in another handler
so to a handler then we do
okay so here welcome to or do
console.log Lord I say a second handler
alright and I'm gonna save the project
is an error it's basically a TS lindara
not an actual coding error so let's go
and take a look at what happens when we
have this so here we have action button
action alert and oh okay
actually a lot I can see okay button and
then cancel button now I'm gonna add
another button here guys and I'm just
gonna name it open model so that's just
to open for action sheet not a model
action machine right and then I'm just
gonna make it let's just say primary
right so I've removed console load so
here in handler you want to start with
typing async and then we'll do an error
function here and then inside these we
are going to create an action sheet so
here you can see I've already imported
action sheet controller and objected
that in a constructor as well
so let's go down and here we want to
start writing over how to shoot so here
I'll just create a Const and I'll do
action is equal to then we'll do a rate
they start action sheet create and that
also takes an object and take some
properties that can be used so do some
sort of header so we'll define some
buttons here as well so I'm gonna -
header and I'll just say testing action
then also we can define a role as well
but let's not define a role let's define
an icon and as to trash and the world
can also define a handler two days so
that's not gonna go there so we need to
define a button guys so as I've shown
you how
do it so this is to a button here and
then the first button text is going to
be terrorist and they would do roll we
can define a role to cancel then we have
a handler again and then inside the
handle use error function syntax to
console the Lord a hello
okay with a saved project and now we
should see an action sheet but before we
can see that we need to present that so
here I'll find this action sheet and I
find this this calibrates and after this
we wanted to wait this dot action dot
present okay now while we're here so we
don't need this we just simply use a
wait action dot present and that's
pretty much it is so it just gonna
decrease the text size and let's take a
look at so we click on this we get
election and when I click on open action
sheet click on this and you see then
action sheet as well so that's cool
isn't it so you can define alert or you
can define action sheet and you can
perform any kind of action while a user
tweaking of that so that's really cool
now I'm going to take you some of the
documentation of ionic and let's take a
look at some of the things that we need
to know about this documentation how to
use the stock communication and how you
can improve your knowledge of ionic and
need to group your work flow +
creativity + productivity using these
documentation so now you can see we have
a lot more options here we can create
these kind of alerts so here we have a
long message alert we have a multiple
button alert which we created alert no
message we have a confirm and cancel
button
also we have some sort of a form that
can take data from user and perform an
action on okay or dismissed
alert on cancel so let's take a look at
we have creating so this is how it we
like alert using alert insurer then we
can define the buttons we can define
inputs using input this is a so code
snippet that you can use all the way
down we can see we have a properties now
the properties are basically a value
that you can use to do some stuff for
example he'd say it's animated so it
says if true alert would animate and
it's default to true so if I click on
this and then you see the animation
happening so it's like here you see that
animation so if I go and write on the 12
I can say I don't want to I want I don't
want it to any main so I'll change the
value and limit it to false and I saved
the project and I see if I click on that
normal animation should happen so here I
click it pops up straight away so
there's no animation happily now as you
can see you can read about these
properties and you know customize your
alerts or you can customize any other UI
component so every time you want to use
a button and actually sheet alert or
card or card title editing the
documentation of that technology is the
best place to enhance your knowledge so
here we have a backdrop I'm just going
to copy that
let's go back and then here we define as
I said backdrop dismiss it is the right
key so here it says backdrop - dismiss
so we will do actually let's not do that
we do something else here okay back -
are they true the Lord will dismissed
when the backdrop is clay default so
true it's already
we want to find overlay that's gonna be
basically it's gonna make the background
a bit a bit darker so you can see the
overlay there now these are all the
properties that you can use to customize
your your alert also if I will show you
guys few other things so for example
here we have icon iron button so if you
want to use a button in your application
you can simply use this iron button so
let's take a look at how we can use that
here we have a code snippet so here I'll
use ID button with the color primary let
me just do success let's copy this and
then here we have some issues here so
I'm just gonna remove this but save the
project and it's close some files here
we go home that page the HTML file and
here our to use iron button with color
success I'll save the project and you'll
see our server results automatically
into bottles over app and show that this
is success better right now this better
doesn't do anything let's take a look
how we can improve this here we have a
button time we can define that as a
button or bar the color property we have
already used here and I will define its
value success this is how we can see
this color success there all the way
down we have all the options for example
you have the size if you want to make a
button larger or small then you can
define that so here if I say size which
is a property and I said large and I
press command asked to save the project
and it will recompile it it will seem
change so here we have a larger better
now taking you you can use this
documentation and an improved knowledge
about ionic so yeah that's that's about
it for this button or maybe last thing
we look at shape you might like to share
so here we have
a property shave and then that can only
take this properly the possible values
are around let's keep it around and
let's save it let's see if we get
something different so yeah we have the
round value there so similar to this we
have a badges you can use this HTML also
all the time please go inside API and
which will give you a list of properties
you can use for that URI component you
can look at what are the methods you can
call on that for example we will do some
method so go to alert and we go all the
way down after the properties we have
events which we'll talk about later so
here we can call that methods as well we
have these methods like dismiss or we
have this on will dismiss basically in
weed that this is what's going to happen
when you apply this to a button or any
which can act upon it this will dismiss
the alert overlay
we're gonna continue our ionic adventure
of components
so you've seen action sheet I've
explained to you how you can use alert
badge button now we're gonna go and
complete our knowledge about UI
components insert things that I want to
talk to you guys about so let's just say
is some of the components you see we
have HTML for that so you can use these
components there are basically static
components that can be used in your
application but some of the components
are dynamically created for example if
we want to create a checkbox then you
use this ion check box if you need to
find the properties which are available
and then you can do that so here you can
see we got all the tech check boxes here
that can be used so if I go to API and
then I will see all the properties for
checkbox I can use so these are some of
the some of that code snippet that can
be used and it gives you some of the
idea that how you can use these UI
components in your application for
example this one is dynamically done
here so here we are on a list which is
another UI company we have an iron item
we'll use the angular ng for array and
then we loop through to all of these
checkboxes then you can see bunch of
checkboxes using this ng for that's fine
so now let's take a look at our
components back so we have a date and
time picker so if I go didn't I picker
you can see in a lot of application that
you have this kind of a date and time
picker as well so here we have a type
picker nicely done and it will
automatically adjust its UI according to
the platform you're using so we have a
and fab 20 1990 so this is how you can
use data and time picker now let me take
you to the API we'll take a look at some
of the properties for date and time
picker
which is actually an important one
because a lot of application pretty much
every application has to work around
data and time so here we can see we can
form it our date and time by defining
these values so let's go and use this
day and time picker and let's take a
look at how we can use it so I'm going
to take you back to the code let's just
remove some of the button here let's
save this project now let's learn from
here so basically we can do a date and
time picker I'm going to go and find
basically this code snippet here
it's in a copy this and I'm going to
paste that here I'm going to save the
project and let's see if we were able to
see that in time so if I click on this I
see this you know January 1 18 and then
time as well so here you can see we have
a property called display - for mate
let's go back and would take a look at
what are the properties available so
here we have I on date and then we have
a formatter that can be used so here we
have a form it and then basically for
for--why defines year in four-digit true
why I defined here in two digits one and
defined a month and in one digit so
let's go and take a look at and use this
so here we have a four why why I'm going
to change that to two why I'm in control
on the windows and commander in the Mac
press s to save the project let me go
and just hi our project so we could see
the whole code if I click on this now
this time I should see a year in two
digits so you can format your didn't
time using all these values so let's
just say if I don't want to show the
time here I'll simply go and remove at
at column and M and I save the project
by pressing can
as and that should update our app and
should only show me date with month and
then day in the year in two digits so
you can see here you can use these
values and customise them into a date
formatter so here it tells you how to
use it so you can see this property now
we can even format the picker as well so
here if I change this format picker and
I'll just copy this property and then
let's just paste it here let's just save
it and let's see what happens there here
we got an error with if we goes into a
semicolons let's uh save the project
again and let's see what happens now
let's refresh and let's see if we can
see the changes
okay I'm gonna click here and then now
we have the pickup for meter we have a
month and then we have this for yyy but
if I change this to true YY and then
save this now this ear should be in two
digits so let's take a look now here you
can see we have a January a month and
then we have this 18 so you can format
your date picker using this picker
format property also we have this
date/time data which can we use to
basically handling date/time values
within JavaScript or HTML so basically
good to base sample and you can see
what's available to you and what you can
do if I go all the way down we have some
min and Max date times for example you
want to define what's the minimum date
here what's the maximum so if I go here
I'll just do this I say mean is equal to
as I said two zero one five
and before I save it I want to test it
so I'll just do three YY to remove my
voice so I could see the ear in place
you mean four digits so I'll save it and
I wait for it to restart and I click on
this and now I can see I can only pick
from 2015 not before 2015 because I've
defined this properly mean and similarly
I can define the property
Max's odds right now max is 2018 but I
can define max is equal to let me go and
find so that's the date we can do copy
and we can paste it and here I want to
say okay this is to true true to 20 it's
compiling and let's go to the next
century garden so here that's the max
and then we can go all the way to 2015
as well that's a date and time picker if
you go down you will see a lot of usage
how you can use it and sample codes we
have some properties the cancer tax day
names so you can customize this this is
really cool stuff here going on I can't
make everything available to you guys in
this one video I'll do a separate video
just covering date and time I'm going to
close this and let's go to the fab a fab
is another company which needs a
separate video so I'm going great if you
are coming from bootstrap background you
understand how you can define the grid
so I'm not gonna go into details
infinite scroll is one of the nice
component that it can be used for a lot
of data processing so you have like a
hundred and phase you can't show your
100 entries in small screen so what are
you doing you create an infinite scroll
so when people go all the way down they
can basically load more data right we
have a generic input field as well so
let me take you to dark
mutation of input can we use this so
let's go here and now I can show you the
code snippet so for example we have this
let's just do something like a floating
label let's just to copy this and then
just paste it so right here let's save
it and let's see what comes up so here
we have define a label on label and we
have an input so this says a floating
label so if I click on that that's nice
animation you see this is what happened
so if I do like you know remove this
then I save this again now I'm pretty
sure you're not gonna see that animation
there so let's just go click and you
can't click anymore because it's not
going up so you cannot have an input
field there so now you can see and read
about this as well eirick input fields
in our text password number so tell
let's do a number so I'm going to change
these two back to floating position and
inside this ionic input I need to type
tight is equal to with you a number I'm
gonna save and now once I start tapping
I should see a number picker here so you
see this I can do I can pick the number
from here that's not really natively
showing you how you can type the number
but once you open that in your mobile
application in your mobile it will show
you the lamp I so we can do something
like a towel let's just change this to
tell and save it let's see what happens
now
so here I see I can define the alphabets
also we can define a telephone number
so yeah that's out that's that's you can
use all this text password email your I
need to do a validation that which I'll
have a separate video write something
like cancel out and we go to the next
your company now one of the companies
Lodi which is great so we move around
your applications from one page to
another page sometimes what happens is
when you go to the next page you have to
make an API call which will wait for the
data to come back now take the time if
you don't let user know anything that
what's happening if the data is coming
up or not then that's really a bad bad
thing to do to the user so what we do we
create a loading that's we tell the user
wait hang on a second it's loading the
data and it's gonna show that so click
on show loading and that should show
something like this and also if we go to
API we can change the design of it as
well so let me go and let's create a
loading actually so - oh lordy by using
loading controller we creat that
similarly an async function and we'll
wait and then we define a property
duration and a message we can also
define what kind of spin I want to use
so let me just copy this code from here
and I will go and paste it in our home
page that tasty file that's just sorry
ts file so here we don't have a loading
so we're gonna go up there and I'm just
gonna press ENTER you know do private
there what was the name of that variable
so just to copy I'll just do a paste
here and then I'll - loading L okay
think controller and that's gonna come
from ionic angler as well for this
pasted here let's save this project and
also it's something wrong you guys so we
want to do is comma here when we define
it more than one we injecting a service
right let's save the project and now
we're going to call this function
present loading without options on this
copy this you go here we create another
button so let me just make this smaller
and it will just copy this we paste this
button and I still say loading action
and we paste that oops
no we need to go back it's gonna copy
this go back here and paste it here
let's save the project and let's call
this function and then let's see if we
see the loading or not if I click on
loading that should give me this loading
here it says our learning we have a
spinner hide duration five seconds
message please wait it's a transplant
true if there's any CSS custom class I'm
just going to remove the CSS custom
class and I'm going to remove this as
well but let's try to find out what are
the nice
what is nice loading available for us so
we'll go here we have this sort of like
okay he goes we have a spinner property
and we can do lines lines small dot
circle bubbles let's do a bubble and
then we do paste a bubble here and
that's just compile and then refresh the
page let's click here and then there you
go that's the bubbles now we see the
bubbles yet if we want to change this to
let's just say dots let's copy this and
it's just pasted
here and save it and we should see a
reload on the page and I'm gonna click
on that then we have dots now so you see
how cool animation that can be done
using loading that's closest you
understand how to use it there are some
methods that you can call on this like
we did call this present method on the
loading we could call a dismiss method
on the loading which will dismiss the
current loading happening and that
transferred property was there by
default so say if true the loading
indicator will be Transco translucent
defaults to false yep so that's makes
sense we have a mode we can define if
it's a iOS motor MD board let's try that
so do more I do
MD will add a comma here let's save it
let's take a look if the mode makes any
change to our UI
of loading let's click on that now we
are we seeing a rectangular a loading
box which is good right it's not
transferred so we do something like
transferred and I will do to true sure
this is to cover here let's save it and
then we should see a reload
let's just click on that and now we have
some subtle trance : i translucent so
let's go back when it closed loading
let's go and let's skip menu and let's
skip the model as well and also let's
hit the navigation because that's a bit
of a lengthy process
Lentini component to explain we will pop
over
that's just like a top header which
basically sees what's happening
underneath so here I go down you see
this text underneath we have a range
sometimes you want to increase or
decrease the brightness of your iPhone
or application you can do this range as
well and change the values dynamically
refresher as I said with loader you can
do a refresher so you tap and slide down
and then it will load more data to it so
you can call it the event so let's go to
the API let's take a look at what we can
do so in the refresher refresher
provides pull to free fresh
functionality on a content I component
the pull to refresh pattern lets the
user pull down on the list of data using
touch in other in order to retrieve more
data so we have this complete so let's
take a look at a usage now so we will do
or copy and paste this and that will
leak entirely this is going to also this
is what happened I on a refresh and then
we do refresh and passing it in bed in
our TS file we have this function to
refresh and then set timer to 2000 so
this is how you can do a refresh and
then do your logic in this refresh
function okay so there are some
properties available for that as well
you can play with them we have something
called cancel complete and get process
function and they actually all makes
sense by the name of the function
for example cancel it changes the
refresh you stayed from refresh me to
canceling
that's okay complete call it complete
when you're a sync operation
completed for example the Refresh
instead is while the app is performing
an async crosswalk and so you can call
this function as well get process makes
really sense straightforward sense so
let's cancel out and then we go to
search bar pretty simple guys satisfies
just you know search bar which can do
some filtering as well and ionic
basically provided an API for that as
well as select a select is something
that you click and then you have an
option to select right so we have a
December we have two option to select
it's basically a selection of two you
can define more than two as well slides
now slides are great when you have an
application starting for the first time
in your phone you want to be able to
show some masseter some tutorial to the
user of that app so slides a great way
to show that and a lot of application do
that as well as once you start your
application for the first time it will
show you some slides with - information
spinner we can see the spinner already
we have different types of spinner tabs
we skip the tab because we're going to
be creating a separate video for tabs
toast toast is something that will pop
the message out for temper for a
specific amount of time so similar on a
click command it just show you some of
the toast that you can see you can put
the messages in that that's very
straightforward I wish you'll scroll
same thing that you just go and scroll
down keep scrolling up to where you want
it what you want to allow user to scroll
to that's good as well so I'm going to
show you a toast API let's go here and
here we can find really cool stuff so
you have a toast here which comes from
top to bottom we can see the properties
so here we have a property of animated
if you want any with that or not when we
spend with specify a property they've
animated and then we'll put the value
it's a boolean
so either takes true or false
duration can specify the direction and
after distribution the what he called
this yeah I on toast will be dismissed
okay
remote Overland exposition that you can
define top middle bottom if we have this
it's in the middle we have a top we have
a bottom so you define those positions
by defining a position property and
giving a value either top middle or
bottom to show close button if you have
a close button there then you can
basically show a close button it doesn't
show here but you can define a shovel
and so by default fall because you won't
see a close button here right that's we
have some events as well we got method
similar to other you accompany the
present and present this toast on will
dismiss it returns a promise that
resolved and the toast will dismiss this
miss actually dismisses the toast and we
have some custom properties properties
as well which we can use to customize
the layout or look of that toast so we
pretty much covered all the basic UI
components and you understand how to use
them by and reading about the
documentation in API page that can help
you how you can customize those
components alright so in the next video
we are going to create a layout with
tabs and also with a sidebar
so so far we have done about nine videos
of ionic so I think this is the right
time we will use all that knowledge and
create a UI for our project so let me
show you what we're going to be creating
in this video we're gonna be creating
this tab bar and also this tab bar UI
has a side bar as well so type and
sidebar is implemented in this UI so we
click here we see the side bar we can go
and click on that menu and go to the
next page or we can switch between these
pages as well also we have this nice
action sheet implemented here so having
a tab bar and a side menu side by side
it's quite complicated in ionic 4 so
before we start off with you guys I want
to show you guys my JavaScript course
which is available on udemy I'll drop a
link of that course in the description
below with the coupon which will give
you about 70% off so please have a look
if you're interested in learning
JavaScript let's get started building
this UI using ionic floor which includes
a tab bar and a side bar side by side
right guys let's go and create a new
project we'll use a blank template and
don't work from blank template so we
know everything which it takes to build
that user interface so let me just
increase the font size here so I'll do
ionic start and I'll do - - time would
be angular and that's name or project
ionic tutorial and then we're gonna use
a blank template that's integrated over
and that's about it it's gonna take few
seconds before it drains a project and
after that we're gonna open that product
in web strong so now let's take a look
at a blank project so you've already
seen that three times but this tutorial
is gonna be I'm gonna just you know be
quick as possible to create this UI
let's go to the app and here we have a
main component app and also we have a
home component let's go to the terminal
and start our application so ionic sir -
L it's gonna ask me if I want to install
ionic lab which I'll say yes please
install and then it's gonna open the app
in the browser right so we have this app
up and running so first of all we're
gonna go and implement a sidebar so to
implement sidebar
we're gonna go to app component and I'm
just gonna decrease the size here and
let's just do okay so in app component
we defined the list of the side and many
we need so I will create a variable here
and I'll let it public and I'll say app
menu
so we created a variable which is an
array and it lists out three objects
which we'll use to generate our side
menu all right so let's go to app
component HTML file and inside this file
I'm gonna start writing ionic split pane
so we have a unexplained which will have
like a split pane there if you are a
developer or you've worked on that you
should be able to familiar with that so
we were ionic split pane and also inside
this we want to create ion menu and
inside the menu we will have a toolbar
so on menu that's where I on header
first so we have header inside these
will have toolbar and inside the toolbar
will have I on title which will have
time as a minibar so inside this we
gotta add menu we got this I on header
we got our toolbar and inside our
toolbar will wrote I on a menu let's get
out from the header and then we do on
content so we do on content inside this
we want to create our own list and
inside the list will do I on that menu
- toggle we do Auto hide here yep let's
do Auto hide we set that to false and
then we do ng4 let's do a star here in
g4 is equal to let P off what is the
name of the variable that we created
that was app menu let's go back to app
component and here we do menu and then
we'll just
let's just do something let's just use
something here now do on I - and then
we're gonna have this router Direction
implemented that we set is equal to root
also the router link so do router link
is equal to and here we'll use this as P
dot URL that's gonna be our your our
link so that's that's our item inside
this iron item we want to have a label
so I am label that can be P dot label or
title actually yes that's the one
let's save everything and also the last
thing we want to do is we want to move
this I on router outlet to inside this
aren't split plane and here we're gonna
type main we said that I'll browser
outlet main so we'll save this and now
let's go through so basically we have a
iron app we have an ion split pane we
have ion menu and then inside harmony we
have on header and sat on how do we have
an toolbar and in the title and then we
did on content we create ion list many
toggle and then inside the many toggle
we created an iron item and then we
define the router direction to route and
also rather link to P dot URL and then
we close this we close the least regard
this router module inside I on split
pane and we define this property main to
our router module that's going to save
this and once we save this you see
there's nothing
happen the reason why we define all this
in app component but we have not defined
this into homepage because when the
application start through lazy loading
it automatically goes through the whole
module and it opened up this home
component if you look at the routing
module you see that if there's no part
it will go to the home so let's go and
use this menu to the home so let's go in
and title we do something like our iron
header and on toolbar
we'll use say I on - buttons we do a
slot off let's just say start so we're
gonna push the button to the left right
so let's close this and inside these we
just use iron menu button that's it you
saved and let's see what we have so Bo
not Bo we actually have a be you there
let's save it again let's let it compile
and we should see our menu so here you
can see we have this we'll click on this
and it opens up and we have this title
we have this text - we have this test3
there we go so we created our menu
successfully now we can do some menu
customization here I'm going to go back
to app component and here we can say the
type would be overlay that'll same days
and let's take a look at on it gets
compiled and here we'll click and you
see this overlay here now so we're
getting like basically a backdrop sort
of effect when you're many opens also we
can define icons here as well so in an
item we can have let's just say inside
this an item order - iron i con and then
the icon would be let me just grab that
so icon can be
from the object as well so we'll do a
slot first we said that to start and
then name of that let's just do from P
dot icon but save it and now let's take
a look at what do we get so I'm just
gonna make it smaller now guys I think
it's already really big so let's click
here and then here we can see we can we
are loading icons dynamically from our
object alright so now we have
successfully done over a side bar menu
let's work on at a bar so for that I'm
going to generate a new module so to
ioniq generate I'll use this as let's
just say a module should be fine okay
and then we'll name as tags it's gonna
go and generate a module in the tab
there you go we have a module there now
inside these we're gonna create another
routing module so I'll do I on ik g
module - - routing and then we do tabs
let's take a look at if it generates a
tabs around module it says could not
generate module it's already exists okay
that's fine
but let me just get rid of this okay we
will look at out routing module that's
not there that's cool app module that
wasn't there as well that is cool as
well so we do I need to grade module - -
routing so what it will do it will
basically generate a module with a
routing as well so here you can see we
have a module okay and then it
automatically imports tabs around a
module which we have here and most of
the world we're going to be doing in
this tab around a module but for that
we're gonna need another
ts file that is basically it's gonna
help us to you know do all the you are
his stuff and also we can generate a fab
module as well so what I'm gonna do here
I'm going to create a file so we'll do
do generate and - - flat and then I'll
do a component and then we do tabs slash
tabs now let's take a look so now we got
a module let's take a look at the
routing module let's look at a module
that's cool
we got tabs that component file as well
we have a tabs component file there as
well so that's cool guys now we can
start working on our tabs so first of
all let's just score in the routing
module and here we want to define some
sort of routing
[Music]
after that we want to make sure that our
tab component is available in tab start
module file so in the declaration we're
gonna have to have tabs component
injected so I'm gonna save the file and
now we're gonna go to tabs that
component HTML file and write our eye on
tabs here I'm just gonna make this eyes
bigger if first of all would do eye on
tabs and then eye on that tab now in the
tab
we're gonna have some properties let's
say attributes first of all what would
be the label so we'll do a label let's
just say dashboard right and then we're
gonna do an icon as well so he'll -
let's just say Home icon for now down
here we are doing H ref is equal to that
would be tabs slash home : home okay
now inside the tabs we wanna have a
router as well so if you remember in the
tab so in the tab riding model we
defined outlet so name was home so we
simply go and say I on router - outlet
and then in there when I have a name
which set to the same name baby when I
go to I'm gonna save the tab file and
after compiling the project you should
be able to see the tab so here we have a
home dashboard tab so let's go and
generate some more module so we're gonna
go to new terminal here I'm going to
generate a page so we'll do let's just
say a page
select the page and we'll do about Us
page right it'll generate all the things
that we need that we do we generate
another page let's just say contact okay
as you can see we have two pages about
in contact and now we're gonna inject
out to routing module so here we have
two pages about us and contact so we
basically don't want to do that here
because we're not going to target them
from uploading module so we just wanna
control xre
we just want to move both and then paste
them into tabs rally module and now here
we are going to define some more part
here so let's just take a look at couple
more things a home page is basically
coming from this part let's go to add
module and then first of all let's
import those module here so we do about
to say about us module and then we have
a contact
Paige module so we got two modules there
now you're up routing
so now let's copy-paste this is copy and
then paste this twice and that would be
let's just say about and then we have
about that would be about page as well
okay so basically we're saying part is
about and outlet is about and the
company we're gonna target is about as
fit as we imported our module into the
tab module so we can target that now
here we can say contact and then contact
and that would be a contact page right
now we're gonna go to tab component and
here I want to make a copy of these so
it's just a copy of these this is going
to be about icons going to be about this
is going to be about the time and now
here we're gonna go to tabs so here in
the rowdy tabs running modules we have
this reading the parties tabs and then
that's a tab component which read
basically having that same folder the
children of those is this we have the
children about us page and a children is
a contact page and the reason why we can
access this here is because we have
important both modules in our tab module
so here when I go to let's go back here
and he wanna do tab slash about about
here I wanna do contact and
contact lets me make it a bit smaller
let's just to contact I can't let's just
to contact and then contact us around
model so we will save the project now
you will notice after getting compiled
that you will have about and about if I
click on about odo
take me to contact page I'm gonna go
change this to contact and now the icon
is not available there so I'll just do
chart okay I will do the pie here let's
just just random thing okay I'm gonna
save the project and now we can see we
have about click here it takes us to
about Us page click here it takes us to
contact page click here it takes us to
dashboard page now within those pages if
you want to see a menu bar so go to
about page and in the toolbar will do I
on - buttons and then we do our on -
menu
button okay let me just make it bigger
so see we have an iron menu button and
inside our button so save it and now
let's go to about page and we should see
this sidebar there as well so you have
decided by there we should be able to
see the same sidebar here now the same
thing when I copy days and we're gonna
go to contact page and let's just do a
paste here
in the toolbar let's just save it and
now our word tabs and Cyberman is
working so here we go contact page we
have a side bar menu if we go to a
balance page we have a Cyberman so just
to show you guys that this is right so
here we are at contact page I'll do at
file and say this this is the contact
page and then I'm going to just copy
these we're gonna go to about page I'm
gonna paste that here as well
let's say about page let's save the
project and let's take a look if we're
actually moving to different pages now
so here we are in the about page we can
go to dashboard we can go to contact
page here you can see we have this many
one as well so this is how you can
create an application using an
application with tabs and also the side
permanent now if you want to start your
application with this kind of layout
then you can download this from my
github it's just gonna be gonna clone
the repository and there you're you
don't have to worry about adding all
this boilerplate code so you got this on
my github account and I'll share the
link with you guys as well
alright so this is how you can create a
tab plus a sidebar menu using ionic 4
I'm gonna be showing you a cool trick in
ionic so I started building an
application using ionic framework
recently and I really liked it but there
were few things that I wanted to to
enable for me to build a faster in ionic
so the first thing I would like to show
you that how you can debug your
application right in your IDE whether
it's a web strong or it's a vs code
would look at a web strong in this video
also I would like to show you that how
you enable code or WA in your browser so
you can start debugging while having
lower enabled there were a few things
that was not really working so I had to
find a trick or a way to fix that let's
take a look at the problem first so if I
will go and start this average ionic
server that will open my browser which
you can see on the right and it will
start the application so new application
instance has been started so I'm going
to log in with one of the email address
that I signed up with before and I'm
gonna say the password would be whatever
the password type it in now if I click
on login it's not logging in so let's
take a look at the browser developer
tools and I'm just gonna push that a
little bit to the left and now the error
beginning is it says crude or not enable
error in sign-in going to tap space okay
so what happening is when you use I onyx
and native API basically ionic has an
API which lets you access the device
hardware for example if you want to
access the camera on your iPhone using
ionic framework you're gonna have to
have a Java plug-in installed so you
could access that hardware so if you
don't have a door enabled in your
browser you can't do that so this this
is the one problem another thing that to
fix it you could emulate with the
browser so for example I will go
and I stop this I'll say ionic Cordura
and wet browser now I'm waiting on a
browser will fix this code or problem
but there is another problem with
emulating browser which is you cannot
live reload so whenever I change my code
it should reload the browser
automatically and let me see the changes
that doesn't happen when you do ionic I
could go up emulate browser it does not
really provide that so that's the
problem so right now if you look at the
terminal it's actually adding Cordova
plugins to the build so you can start a
browser wit curl or were installed it's
taking a bit of time at the when you
start the first time so I'm just gonna
pause the video I come back when it's
done okay so my wedding is started now I
can see in the console I can login so if
I go to for example always at gmail.com
I'll go type the password I enter and
now I can log into the app and here I
can see there is no correlation anywhere
I can use firebase plug-in I can use any
sim a plug-in which is required Cordova
so let me go and sign out and let's go
back so right now if I would like to
debug this page which is running on
localhost 8080 bugging configuration
here so I'll just go and paste it here
apply ok now if I start the debugger
and I try to look sign in and here I
want to do a break one so if I click
here this is very init app and I'll
refresh this you can see I can have this
debugging enabled right because our
server was only 8,000 so this is good
but I won't be able to live reload my
application
for example if I let it go and if I go
to any of the page for example login
page and I change the name here from Los
Angeles is ABC and I save and now you
can see it actually brought the
application it did not reload
automatically I'm gonna stop the
debugger guys and well let's go back to
this ionic serve and let's go to
terminal let's go here I'm gonna stop
the server and we simply say ionic serve
and that should open the browser again
and it should give me an occurred over
error but I will be able to live reload
my application let's take a look so I'm
just gonna close these tabs and here you
can see I have ABC now so if I go change
this back to Laura Keene and ice it's
command S on a Mac and I can see it's
building and it's reloading the
application now I want to have a kid or
enabled here so how do we do that
is is applying the street so what I'll
do I'll go to this platform where I
actually build if you do ionic Cordova
platform add browser and also you do
ionic could over build browser you'll
get this folder in the platform so what
I'll do I'll just copy this www folder
and I go back and I just right-click on
the the parent folder which is
expeed Marga right now and I'll just
paste here and I'm gonna click OK and
I'll tell me okay you have the same
names in the folder which is basically
having same numbers in the in the next
folder we're copying so I'm just gonna
do all right for all now once I
overwrite everything I would see that in
our www folder which is used to to
launch your application when you do
ionic serve I'm gonna just expand that
and here now I have a code or one before
I did not have a code or because when
you do on yourself it does not really
add curd or stuff into
the WWF order so what I did was I
applied a trickier where I am elated our
built a browser project and I copied
over this ionic I copied over to
www.irs.gov one once it's all let's go
to the console and take a look at that
okay so now this is running through
ionic syrup and it's live reload is
enabled because it's from ionic cell so
let's take a little console yeah right I
don't have any arrows anymore
can I log in using this Fabrice or just
to gmail.com or the password that's
entered and there you go
the kadoya is enabled and it's working
now anytime I make any change so let me
go log out and it's closed days and we
make a door enabled and I can do a live
reload as well so to do command s and
there you go it's updating the
application on the fly with live reload
feature and also you have akadama
enabled so the only time you will have
to copy this platform ww folder and
override the outer world of the folder
when you have another new plugin
installed from code or for example you
go and install a camera plugin which
were not available before in your
application then you will have to build
a browser project and then copy the code
OVA or WWE folder into the out of the
little folders right now if I just go
and delete this folder last thing we
check okay so I'm just gonna go and
let's just delete this folder right you
can see that it was it had a hood over
there but now if I do ionic serve it
will build this doublet of little bit
further for me but it will not have that
kind of stuff in it let's take a look
face building there you go
so right now we
you see we have assets bill index.html
and I'll accept hTML is actually
expecting this
caldor's GS which is not available there
right so what I'll do I will just go to
platform and take a look at what we have
in this folder so the difference between
this folder in this folder it had this
Cordoba GS source files a plug-in folder
also Jes
a J's file and in Cordova plugins yes
so if you copy or these three folders in
file then it will start working with
Cordova enabled in application and that
was a cool trick I try to research
online a lot how to enable a live reload
in browser emulation but I couldn't find
any and I came to know that this is not
enabled Bionic team so I figured out
this trick that you could apply and you
can this is just a workaround
you know talk about ionic native so
ionic native is is basically a wrapper
for co2 a plugin that makes adding
native functionality to ionic app easy
so you can use a lot of native stuff by
using ionic native for example you might
want to access the camera on your device
so you can go and use a camera plug-in
you want to maybe use for example you
want to use a date picker you can do
that so there's a lot of things
available here pretty much everything
you're required to build any app now
today we're gonna be using native sites
a lot of times you will need to store
some information to your local device so
if you are running your application on
iPhone you might want to store something
through iPhone so for that we're gonna
be using a native storage API it's a
native storage API variable stores a
very built in Android and iOS so I'm
gonna take you to about strong and an
app that we have it's a blank template
I'm gonna install a native storage
plugin so here this is an app running so
we have a input field shape we have a
get button so we can basically save
something to native storage and then get
it back
so what wanted to is I want to stop the
browser and I want to emulate these to
the iPhone emulators
so we're gonna go and type in a terminal
ionic emulate or we can say ionic
Cordura emulate iOS - - target and I
define iPhone let's just say iPhone 8
okay and it's gonna take some time and
build my project let me take you back to
ironing native and we can look at the
documentation here here you can see you
can so clever plug in by just typing in
this canal into terminal with field oh
and grab Cordoba plugin for you and then
you can install NPM install our nickname
it's storage at beta I give you an
example how you can use this native
plug-in which basically makes our life
very very easy I'm gonna be making
couple of videos just to show you guys
some some tricky native plugins that
requires some instruction but pretty
much all of these you can use by just
going to their API documentation and
look at this usage section which will
pretty much explain to you how you can
use this API and how you can customize
it will tell you everything about this
basically so we'll go to native storage
where it was here and let's take a look
at or emulator hasn't started yet so all
do or just copy this line of code here
and I'm just gonna go and paste this
into a terminal and we just copy this
and I wait for terminal wait for
emulator to start
whoever has started I can see the same
app running in an emulator now so you're
gonna have to use code or walk off if
you want to use native plugins in your
browser and you might have to do I own
accord or emulate a browser instead of
using just ionic serve so now I have
these two functions save to Neddie and
get from Lady so what I'm going to do
I'm going to type something here and I'm
gonna save that to a native storage and
I'm gonna click on get button and I'm
gonna get it back and just show that
here the next thing you want to do is
you want to grab these two commands and
paste them into terminal and install
Cordova plugin and also install anything
native native storage I've already
installed those so I'm gonna go to a
usage section now here you can use this
function to set items and you can use
this function to get items so what are
written those I paste them and configure
them so we'll go to home that yes file
and here you can see we have imported
first of all this latest storage from
native storage and GX as this usage said
and also added that constructor function
here and implement the native stored
into the constructor function then we
have a title and then save to native and
get from native so this is the function
that you write and also what I want to
do is when I save this a title key when
I'm getting back I want to get back data
dot a title also the app won't work
because you have to eject this native
storage into your module so we're going
to go to app dot module dirtiest file
and in the providers I'm just gonna type
a native storage so we'll just do native
storage and add a comma here that save
it now here it's causing an issue
because it's coming from native storage
led sword without an ng ng acts as well
and I want stop ng X let's save the
project and you will see overlap
app will be back on so here now I want
to type hello what are you doing and I'm
gonna save this and this time I'm gonna
just remove this text with an input
field and I won't say gibberish and when
I click on this a cat and then this
letter will be executed so I will do and
get me a title key from a native storage
if I click on I should get back what's
going on click on that there we go so
you have a hello what's going on okay so
this is how you store values into your
native storage whether it's iPhone or
its Android all you got to do is just
use native storage and it's just an
object I get stored in RS and Android
even the windows as well
today I'm gonna be showing you how you
can debug your iOS emulator running your
ionic for application so I'll be doing
ionic for series so this is where I
would like to show you guys how you can
debug your app running on iOS emulator
also you can do the same thing when
you're running your app on your device
using a USB so let's take a look at how
you can debug it's a little bit
different than ionic 3 debugging so
first thing you wanna do is you wanna
start your emulator you can do that by
going to the terminal and going to your
folder where your app is and type of
command any code or emulate iOS and - -
live reload if you wanna live reload the
service for example if I here say hey
and when I command S and it will reload
the emulator and we have things applied
so I'm gonna go back and change this
this is what just I wanted to show you
that you can reload your server so now
I'm gonna go and open Safari so here I
have a Safari and here I'll see there's
a menu called a develop so if you don't
see that what you want to do is go to
Safari got a preference don't advanced
and then here make sure you have an able
show develop menu in the menu bar and
once you have that you close this out
and then click on this develop - and
then click on this simulator and he will
see if you have any emulator running
currently so you go to you'll go to
develop and go to simulator and then
click on this one 92168 3.1 and 3 it
will open up this Safari window and here
you have everything which is running on
your emulator so here if you go to the
sources tab you will see a lot of files
here and these files seems like that
fast but they have subfolder inside them
for example right now I am in tabs
module then I will find in the source
side there's something called tabs -
tabs - motor GS now in the code if you
take a look at I have this app folder
and I have this tab modules and
here I'm lazy loading in the tab module
similar to that if I look it here
I'll go inside the tab and then in the
inside have all the pages related to
tabs module have all the models related
to taps module and add the tabs related
to tabs folder which has some tabs files
for example tabs at yes and also tabs or
module so basically in ionic 3 you had
to go to male GS and you go to next
folder and then source and then app and
here you will see every single thing but
in ionic 4 because we use ionic lazy
loading from angular now so endlessly
has a different kind of lazy loading so
we use that in ionic four that's why we
have to basically load the module before
we can see them in the source tab so
here you don't see a login - login
module say if I got to use the tab in
emulator I'll sign out and that will
lock me in lock me out and show me this
login module which is totally different
thing so now if I look at the sources
tab I see this login - login - module
yes and here I will have all the files
alleged this so for example in my login
dot PHP ml file I should be able to see
this sign-in button and the text should
be sign in so here if I go and change
this let's say hand changes here but
anyway you can see the HTML right here
so if I go to login page at es and I do
a breakpoint here so let me just do a
breakpoint here and I also do a
breakpoint here I'm gonna go to emulator
and when I start typing some email
address and then try to log in to this
app when I click on signing and you will
see a breakpoint getting enabled so here
I can see I'm at this break right now so
it says this router not navigate by URL
city I'm checking tabs module now so if
I let it run it'll take me to the tabs
module so you can see that you can do
you can basically do
break fine but you have to load that
Pacific module to be able to see that in
the sources so here I can see login now
I can see tabs module and everything
related to tabs modules are available
here so let's go back and here I will
show you some of the folder structure
here for example in a tab module if I
click on this routing file I'm gonna go
okay if I go to charts page on a
breakpoint here if I click on chart it
should break one but it wouldn't because
it's not calling this object again and
again already called for the first time
let me just get out and I go to file and
yet they go so here we have a log it
function if I tap on this and if I click
on click me that would just log in here
so this is the function it calls when I
click on clicking you so here you can
see you can log in and you can see
what's happening here
I'm gonna be showing you how you can
debug your ionic for application using a
web strong web some has a great
debugging tools this is what I'm gonna
show you in this video it's basically
simple JavaScript debugging - ok so I'm
in the project and I'm my app running
here then you can start the server let
me go to terminal
and I'll say ionic search and it's gonna
start the server on port 80 100 on
localhost and I can see there your AB AB
sorry localhost 80 100 now once that
start and when I go and configure my
debugger in I only so I can go to tools
and here I will have actually we can go
from outside so here we have a debugging
tools so I'm gonna go to click here and
click on edit configuration I'm gonna
delete one of them I have already so
click on class and then I go to
JavaScript debug and here I'll name it
ionic for debug and I want to target the
URL which is basically login sorry
localhost 80 100 so that's localhost
colon 80 100 and that's it I'm gonna
apply that when I click OK I'm going to
go back to this edit configuration one
more time and you can see it
automatically apply this HTTP colon
slash slash that's fine click OK now
here I want to click on this green
button and it will start the debugger
nothing we want to make sure that we
have is called jetbrains IDE support
extension in chrome if I got a new tab
let me show you yeah
as you can see here it says ready for
connection from JetBrains IDE support
okay that's motor installed so what I'll
do is I'll go to Chrome Web Store and
here I will search for JetBrains
and that's going to be this extension
JetBrains IDE support click on add to
crude and you will be adding this to it
so I have actually already installed
that but I will have to enable it's a
little more tools and not extensions and
here at the bottom I can see this is I
checked when the IT support is installed
but it's not enabled so I'm going to
click on enable button I will it will
start an application in in Chrome
browser with Chapman's IDE support right
now I can see the debugger has started I
can see the console which I used to see
in browser I can have this debugger
tools where I could do breakpoints and
they both and the several breakpoints
also I could just have like next button
here so let me go in first of all log in
here so the always at gmail.com this is
not my real ID guys so don't try to
message me here when I click on signing
and they will sign me in and after I log
into application
well it's still signing in that we check
I think I have a wrong email ID and
password so click on sign in again now
there you're I'm in my app now so here I
want to go to this click button where I
could log what record log something and
also I could do a break one day so I'll
go to this where is at home that pays to
TS and eat the button called
come to the law hello this is what this
button does don't click on this and once
I click on that I can see it's it's
basically using this break point in my
IDE so this is gonna save you tons of
time because you're gonna save a lot of
time back into the browser going to the
source and going to do all the break one
so you're writing a code you can do a
break one right being in your IDE now
let me give you a quick tour of this
debugger tool first of all we have this
button here which basically says resume
program the shortcut key is all to man
are I click on that and it will resume
my application now let's go to another
page where I sign me so I'll go to login
page and here this is the function that
gets called when I click on the sign-in
button here so I'm gonna click log in
here and I want to click here to break
point not login actually break point so
I'll just type in my email address and
I'll do one two three and that should
break one here so here I can see I'm
breaking point and right now I can see
what's in my email if I click on this
that showed me a way that Gmail was
passed into this function but it's the
password that's have a one two three
that is okay and also if I go and resume
my application by clicking on this
button and that will during launch L
will break point here so now it will
take me to this router navigate by URL
and I can see if I just let it go by
clicking on this button that will take
me here okay so now I have a lot of
buttons here I have this current user so
let me find this current user function
which should be in our users page and I
will show me what is the current user so
here I'll do
breakpoint and then I would click on
current user and that should break one
here ok there it's good so in the user
response from this function if I hold or
it says Cordoba not available that's
fine because I'm not running this time
I'm aware that so it will basically show
me so if you go to a debugger you have
this overview of local variables but
ever the values are currently they're
holding which is great also you can do
right click and you can say add to
watcher add to watches so every time
this application runs and pass through
this function you will see this very
boat getting filled in with the current
value of that variable all right that
was a quick introduction to debugging in
very strong
going to be showing you how to use this
HTTP plug-in from ionic for library so I
mean right now a native API section and
here we have this HTTP also I want to
mention that you could use angular HTTP
client module to do your HTTP calls but
by using digs you're gonna get some
benefit for example you're gonna get
this SSL pinning also we have this
background threading all requests are
done in a background thread so there are
some benefits using this native plugin
so yeah let's go and take a look at how
we can use this let's take you to reps
from and here I have the application
ionic to which we were using in the last
video so first thing we're gonna do is
we want to import this plug-in to our
module so we can do that by importing
that plug-in but remember to installed
it as well so here we have two commands
you have to just copy this line of code
I'm just going to copy this I'm gonna go
to terminal and I'm gonna paste that and
press ENTER and it's gonna install this
only Cordova plug-in and also it's gonna
install ionic plug-in - advanced HTTP
also we will install this install a
nickname HTTP breeder I'm just gonna
copy that and I'm going to paste that
here in the press ENTER and it's going
to install that plug-in as well so the
next thing we're gonna go to take a look
at our applications right now in home
page HTML file I have this get button
which calls this function get the
request right and then we have this
another request object so we go to home
dot page the TS file and here you guys
can see we have this request object and
also we have a get request which doesn't
have anything yet so first thing let's
import over HTTP so to import and onto
HTTP will import form ionic native and
also wanna you know add this /ng X so if
you take a look at we have this
a usage section returns me in his /ng
acts so I brought that here now I need
to add this HTTP module into a progress
or you can call it the service so we can
directly inject that into home dot
module TS or you could add that into AB
dot module as well so it's it's okay to
you know add in home dot module TS and
if you want to use this HTTP throughout
your application you better off adding
that AB dot module 30s because you can
use this into any module later on
because that's the parent module so if
you inject that into a parent module
you'll be able to use that in any child
module so we're gonna go and add that to
home dot module of TS file I'm gonna
press enter here and I'm gonna say
providers and provider takes an array
will do HTTP and then also from HTTP
then we're gonna add a comment here and
also I want to add this /ng X now it's
all good now guys so let's go and write
a function here which will help us to
you know do a get request using that
plugin so we have this edge to tip here
I want to inject that into a constructor
so to private HTTP and then HTTP now
inside this function I want to use this
dot HTTP dot get method so I get back to
request three things URL parameters if
there's any and header if there's any so
- just a simple URL now I needed to have
a server running to do a API call so
instead of running my own server I
actually found this JSON placeholder
it's a fake online REST API for testing
and prototyping so that means I could
just use this so it allows to do post
request I get requests a put request and
a delete request so this is basically if
we can test over front end it will test
if our HTTP methods of working or not so
let's take a look at the first one this
is a URL that we can call using it
we module so I could use this fetch but
we're using HTTP advanced plugin for
manic or cordova so here on a type a URL
or paste that here and then a comma and
I just pass in an empty object wise to
parameters we can just threw an empty
one now it's a promise so gonna go to
next line and we're gonna handle that
but then and then I've said if I get the
response back then I want to set that
response to request object so this das
requests or B is equal to response dot
data so if we take a look at the
documentation of irony so when we get
back we get the data back so we get the
response and we have a treating status
data and have us we can take a look at
that on but let's take a look at what
data we get back I want to handle errors
so I'll go to next line I've said dot
catch and it is an error then I can just
you know set back this story quest
object don't you just set that to error
as well so we'll see errors there as
well so now when we get the response
back from this call we save the data
into request object and request object
isn't injected in our HTML file which
you will see what is the request object
you're getting so let's go to terminal
and let's start our emulator so I wanna
do this ionic click the one with RS -
this target is equal to only iPhone 8
and then the extras live reload so when
I just press enter here and we will wait
for over emulator to start so
application is started I'm going to go
and click on this get button ok cool so
we got this user 1 ID 1 a title
delete us a ut it's just a fake data
okay I'm gonna go to this JSON place
over and I'm gonna do the same call here
I'm gonna click on try and let's see
what we get so we've got user 1 ID Ron
okay so that means we're actually
getting the same data we getting the
data from here so if I go to for example
introduce let me see if I can have any
other alcohol so we'll just maybe let's
go to post and then we can do a request
for a post as well okay so do a post or
that's a lot of pause that's like a
hundred posts that I wanna I don't wanna
do that so if I go like you know get
post one which will return me days so
let's go and change this will go to home
that page 30s and I'm gonna go back and
a copy this URL and I'm going to paste
that here I'm gonna save it and now
we'll just get our I'm gonna up and I'm
going to click on get and gain and this
time I get this user ID title son oh
right so we're getting the post now
another thing to notice you guys this is
coming from HTTP which means that we are
actually doing this through SSL so it's
a secure secure API code so this is good
safe use the HTTP client which is in
angular you will have to write some code
or you'll have to enable SSL and
manually so this is how you can use HTTP
module to do your calls also let's show
you that you could do this post request
you could do this delete request or you
could do this put request as well if we
go to JSON placeholder
we go back and I'm gonna go and find and
it post request so you have a post
request
that's post
yes so you could do basically post
request that's gonna be very long video
but you're gonna give a try and
basically what you want to do is you
want to provide these parameters so we
do a URL which would be days / post and
then that body if you want to add
anything into your body for the post
then we have to define and headers as
well and that will just make a post
request
I'm going to be showing you how to use
this SMS plug-in from ionic for library
so let's say in your application
sometimes you want to send an SMS
message to a particular number and you
don't want a user to go and open their
SMS application and then type the number
and then type the message there so
instead what you want to do is you want
to create a button which will take them
to SMS application also type the message
there and also add the number there as
well so we're gonna learn how to achieve
that using this SMS plug-in and this
plugin is supported for Android iOS
Windows Windows 8 Phone as well so first
thing we're gonna do is we want to
install this ionic SMS plug-in I'm gonna
go take you to my terminal and on the
paste this here and press enter on the
terminal that will be installed then we
gonna install NPM install SMS beta then
we go paste that as well okay so next
thing I want to inject this SMS plug-in
to home module dot es file so this is a
module for my home duck page dot HTML
and home that page that yes
so I'll just inject that here so let's
go top I'm gonna top import and then
we'll do SMS and then we want to add
this slash and G acts okay so that's
been imported let's inject that into the
providers so to here SMS and I save this
module file in home that page dot HTML
file and here on a creator I on a button
and that button will say send SMS and
when I click on that I want to call send
SMS
that's it and now it's good she our home
dot page that he is file and here I've
done feedings so I've imported that
plug-in there and I'm added that into a
constructor
that just there so now we're gonna
create the function so to say send SMS
and then inside a base I'll simply call
this thought SMS thought send method and
that sent matter will require two
parameters first one is a phone number
in the second one is a second one is a
message okay so let's start the phone
okay so I'm going to save this file as
well now I have run this application
with ionic serve - C and I'm gonna show
you guys that applications running on
ionic dev app so let me just bring up my
screen with seasoned applications
running so we're gonna tap on a send SMS
now so if I tap on send SMS it will go
up and I message app and it will add the
number there and also it will have this
message already written for me so this
is cool if you wanna provide this
functionality so you don't want to your
customer or app users you don't want
them to type this long message and type
your number so you can get them to you
know send you a message directly by just
simply tapping on this send button now
and you do the hard work
I'm gonna be showing you guys how you
can use native API from ionic for
library now I've given a tutorial of a
couple of API in our tutorial series for
only four but also there's a lot of
api's that are available you could use
from ionic 4 for example you have a 3d
touch so if you wanna write an
application for iOS and you wanna do
something with 3d touch you can go to 3d
touch documentation and read about it
due to the ionic documentation is really
required for every API for every native
plug-in for example here in 3d touch it
tells you how to use this plugin so it's
basically now up to you to improve the
knowledge in ionic 4 so if you want to
go and study further about native API
you can go to any of these API and then
go and read the documentation and so far
whatever we have learned in ionic 4 you
will be able to use any of these API by
just going to the to the this page and
then just clicking on that for example
the device API is pretty simple as well
all you're gonna do is just install the
plugins and then import in your module
and also import in your TS file wherever
you want to use it and then you can call
all of these instance members so you
want to use model items serial UUID a
version whatever you want to get from it
you can use this device money to do that
so that's it for ionic 4 tutorial series
guys this is the last video for ionic 4
and I hope you liked the tutorial series
and yeah I will talk to you guys in the
next series thanks for watching
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you guys later